with any relationship a son or daughter
could be a friend
family member co-worker and then spouse
if there's something you notice
in that relationship you often get
triggered by what you want to do is come
to them and say
hey you know what i realized i often get
triggered by
you saying x now i know i'm giving that
meaning but it would really help me if
we could create an agreement that you
wouldn't bring that up
when we have an argument
we're talking about how to have better
arguments today
what is the argument hangover love that
actually
you know when when we say that to
anybody they kind of get the sense
people have had arguments they've had
arguments yes they've had hangovers too
whether food or alcohol
so the argument hangover specifically
would be that period of time
between having a disagreement we talk
about a romantic partner but honestly
this could be with
a friend a family member and then
there's the things that you say and do
and then it's the period of time that
you feel disconnected
you feel frustrated you may feel guilty
for the things that you said and what
you did that has that relationship feel
either stalled or just really
disconnected and that can last for a day
two days weeks months it can actually
lead to relationships ending
and that argument hangover finally ends
when you get it resolved
fully emotionally which
some people don't that's relationship
sobriety then
in a way right well it's in a way like i
mean i know you'll ask some great
questions about this but
what my pattern used to be was if things
weren't going well in a relationship
and conflicts were coming up sure we
would try and i would do all the yelling
and the name calling and i let my
emotions
have it be a free-for-all but then when
it just got hard i'd leave
and sometimes i think really the i think
across the world that there's a big
conversation about
relationships should be mostly good and
we don't see a lot of
portrayals especially in media of like
what does healthy conflict look like
and how to stay in a relationship even
when things get challenging
so people unfortunately like you said
will just leave the relationship or how
to leverage that conflict
into an opportunity to grow and
strengthen that
understanding and that relationship one
of the things i was talking about toward
the end of last year
is unremarkable depression so a lot of
the time when we see people hit rock
bottom
it's a big deal and there's almost
bizarrely
a bit of glory attached to it perhaps
that's the archetypes that we see in
media
you know when someone has a full-blown
breakdown perhaps they get
sectioned perhaps they need to go on to
some anti-psychotics
but they know like from that bottom
position there is nowhere else to go
like you have to get better that is
where you go the concern that i had this
common
malaise this ambient anxiety that people
have where life
it vacillates from kind of crap
to just about acceptable and then back
down again
and you're right it the the normal the
unremarkable arguments
i suppose over time will compound to
chip away at confidence in a
relationship
to the point where death by a thousand
cuts occurs
divorce absolutely yeah i mean it can be
the small things but even some of the
things that
seem like they're small and people would
just try to brush under the rug
people miss out on the gold that's
inside of that
like even we say to people you're not
upset about the dishes
you're not upset about the socks you're
not even upset really about finances
because sometimes couples argue about
money it's something underneath that
that's getting
triggered and perhaps it's coming from
your past and so
like what you said even though they're
unremarkable people still just don't
even
find the bigger lesson that's available
to them
they don't see relationships as the
place to transform
you we're talking right before we
started right about self-development and
really self-actualization becoming the
best you
and relationships are the most rapid
intense way you can access that but
people don't look at conflicts as really
the place
for that to even get revealed is that
because
we presume that relationships should
just be smooth sailing and
if there's arguments then that means
problem and if there's a problem then
there's
tinder on my phone and you know 3.5
billion of the people of the gender that
i'm attracted to out there i'll just
crack on
right we don't like being disagreed with
right so the moment that our partner
threatens our ego and our ego
gets triggered you're disagreeing with
me you're not getting my
perspective and also you know people do
say things that are damaging
in times of conflict you read about
parts of the book and
we talk about emotional triggers and
that's really what we want to rewrite
the script on
is conflict especially healthy conflict
can be a good thing for your
relationship
and if we can have couples embrace
conflict in a new way
i really think breakups would decrease
divorces would decrease and overall
there'd be more
happiness in relationships i mean we lit
we do live in a society with so much
comfort right so there's a certain level
of avoiding
anything at all that seems uncomfortable
because of the houses we live in
temperature controlled we have food at
our fingertips we have amazon prime
they'll bring anything to our doorstep
immediately
so we do live in a very you know
comfortable society
of course that quick hit of dopamine and
so we don't really have the level of
acceptance or allowance to go into the
uncomfortable defined
what might be in there i wonder whether
there is
thinking about me i try and put myself
into situations of discomfort sometimes
voluntarily sometimes involuntarily by
accident
um quite regularly but i don't
see discomfort in a relationship
as an area for growth that's a paradigm
that i would need to step into
so hopefully today you can deliver that
red pill what are the
outdated beliefs about conflict um
well even the one you just touched on
exactly what you just touched on
is even one that it's bad and that i
should instead
change the partner so the moment things
aren't going well you talked about like
the uncomfortable and people lean away
from that
now of course if there's a line where a
relationship just isn't aligned
right but if there's alignment in the
relationship you have a shared vision
you have a shared
you know values you actually desire the
same type of relationship
and some that's a lot of times where
people need to start what kind of
relationship do we even want to build
towards so if you align in that way
then one of the outdated beliefs is that
conflict shouldn't be happening
and that if we do argue and we get
triggered i mean my triggers
if he judged me based on how i showed up
when i was triggered and
quote unquote gave up on me i wouldn't
get to transform to be the person that i
am
now and so i think just yeah one of the
outdated beliefs being it shouldn't be
happening yeah or
you know rocking the boat you know a
similar one bringing up something more
proactively because it is going to bring
up a conflict
and the analogy here you know really to
your point why does this
seem to be the paradigm right now in
romantic or or any relationship
is because the way we see it and the
very first response
even within our own mind our first
thought and then
our following actions are more like a
boxing match
so it's like the bell rings and now
you're going against that person now
what we want to invite
especially couples into is that
you can take your initial actions your
initial thoughts and following actions
to get yourself on the same side more
like a
basketball team or a football team that
faces an opponent but they do it as a
team
now all of a sudden as a team you're
looking at how do we overcome this
challenge
how do we see this challenge as what it
could provide for us to grow to
strengthen to become a
better team to win the game to win the
championship so if you can take the
steps
to first stay on the same team looking
at the challenge rather than coming at
it like a boxing match
you've changed the game absolutely team
is the word that i had in my head and
it's one that i've been thinking about
a lot recently as well i was a bit of a
bastard
i guess through my 20s with girlfriends
i wasn't a particularly good boyfriend
like just classic
young lad that was a dick um
and there is something that's happened
over the last five years and i really
really hope that all of the people that
i care about that listen to the show and
everyone else as well that i don't care
about
uh that they can have that same
transformation because like i can't wait
to settle down wife dogs kids
because i know all of the work that i've
done and the time that i've spent on
myself
i want to make them better but i don't
think that i would have
had that mindset five years ago and i
can also see another world in which i
would have never moved from being that
person
to being the person that i am now much
more cognizant around my emotions much
more aware of
the texture of my own mind much more
understanding of other people and the
vicissitudes that they're going to go
through in life right um
how much of the development of a
relationship is on the individual and
how much is a combined effort between
the partners
oh my gosh well i'd say it's a hundred a
hundred it's a hundred percent both
right it's and it has been so i
started self-development before aaron
and i ended a previous relationship that
interestingly
he had all the things i'd check off from
a superficial level
you know all the things we would put on
a dating app you know what kind of
career they're funny
they like to exercise all the oh they
like this kind of music
so from a superficial level they met all
those criteria
but there's a thing that needs to be
added to dating apps are you open to
self-development
and that was the big thing that we
didn't align on
he did blame me and project things on to
me
that were really things for him to look
at so okay that relationship wasn't
aligned he wasn't even willing to really
look at that
now i knew what i wanted i wanted yes
all the fun superficial things because
we're human beings and we like those
things but
i wanted someone who was open to
self-development now did that mean the
moment i met aaron he was like yeah sign
me up for every seminar
you're attending no he was like what's
self-development what i went to college
is that what you mean and
it took some time which would be another
story for university over there yeah a
university over there
but basically we
within our relationship look at
everything as an op
like he mirrors things to me so he is
showing things that are within myself
and so we have created a relationship
and it took years to do this
where we see everything as something we
can learn about ourselves
and at the same time something there's
maybe just a dynamic that's not working
so we're playing off of each other and
what i do triggers this and back and
forth so then
yes we look internally but we also and
this is what
i think a lot of people don't even know
is available we learned
relationship skills and that's really
what we teach and so
we aim to learn and practice
relationship
skills together so that we aren't
constantly triggering each other and
just being like we'll work on you
like that's not what you want to do
right how can you handle yourself and
come back to me how can you make sure
that the partner you're about to get
into a relationship with
has the capacity for growth in that way
either an interest the ability to get
over their own inertia
the ability to not be insulted like do
you just say on your first date do you
just
force them to read carol dwight like is
that the solution you just say right
have you read carol dweck if you have
then we can go out together if you
haven't then sorry this isn't going to
work
yeah i really wasn't maybe all that
open or that all that far along right i
had
a point that had math equations in it so
to your point i think you know when we
get down to the point of what is life
really about it's about
evolution of who you are as a person and
you might say
your highest self your spirit's own
evolution
so if that's the purpose then everyone's
on that path
and it's just going to be what step are
you on
so i think just seeing that a partner is
open to
realizing that that is really the
purpose and then taking whatever step
for them so jocelyn invited me to do a
personal development seminar
which i was open to right i wasn't yet
open to reading like let's say wayne
dyer or
neville goddard about consciousness yet
i am today
so i think to your point you can't judge
someone's path
from the beginning or how fast they'll
go
and they might start off slow and go
faster and some point in the middle and
in relationships
you know your partner might be in a
different speed but you know you get on
the the boat together
so i think it's just that initial
willingness to maybe say to a partner
where do you see you would like to grow
and i think
just getting on that path of progress
and evolution
in whatever area is important to them i
think that always evolves to either
spirituality maybe into professional
and i think just being on the path of
progression is really what you're
looking for
if i can share a story that will just
add on to that
because i couldn't take him from zero to
a hundred i couldn't be like
you need to read these ten books and
come to these three seminars
so i really looked forward to your
question
i looked in him is he open to the
conversations and so i remember this
distinct
dinner date it was probably like even
our fourth date
and at the time he went to bars and
clubs a lot and drank a lot
like there was no self-development on
the weekends for him it was
bars and we were at dinner he's like oh
do you want to go my friends we have a
table and all these things and i just
went
no and he's like what do you mean no and
i said well that's not what i desire to
do on my friday night
and so then he he really got curious
about
what well maybe i don't really like to
go that much why am i
going and it started this whole
conversation about how he was doing it
because that's what his friends do
and he just thinks that that's what his
he's keeping his promise by going
and so then we had this conversation
about integrity and i kind of shared
with him things i had learned and
he was open to it and that's what i was
looking for was that he was
open to those kind of conversations yeah
i don't know
what it's like i've spent a lot of time
around a variety of different types of
people
not everyone's growth-minded some people
are more into it than others
but it would be a scary situation for me
to get five years into a relationship
with someone and find out that they
don't have that growth mindset
um because it's going to make everything
so much harder
and yeah i
those are the ones i'm i'm really big
into
revisiting traditions at the moment i
think that we've cast off a lot of
wisdom that we've accrued over the last
sort of two thousand to five thousand
years as a civilization
and i'm not i want people to try and
make it work i don't want people to
divorce i want them to stick together i
want the family to work and all this
sort of stuff
but yeah there are some challenges that
are
unget viable sadly uh what are emotional
triggers
let's talk about them you mentioned it a
couple of times already well even to
that point right like relationships are
going to reveal your triggers
whether you're with the perfect partner
who me matches
all the things you want there will be
things that happen within the
relationship that trigger you
which we would describe as like somebody
poking a sensitive spot
now most people just have their
triggered reaction right and like
they're angry they're sad they're you
shouldn't have done that i wouldn't feel
this way if you didn't do that
and so they make it about the other
person when people have
awareness about emotional triggers it's
really poking something inside that
wants to be looked at
okay wow where'd that come from why did
that trigger something in me
and if people instead of going outside
all about you and looked inwards there'd
be something really powerful that could
be
shown anything where you died yeah and
the steps of what it looks like is
there is a triggered event
and this can happen again in any
relationship there's in this case with
my partner
expression on the face a specific word
maybe swearing bringing up the past some
action
even a tone and that in and of itself
as you probably shared lots of times
with your audience doesn't inherently
have any meaning
but it's a trigger because that event
elicits
some emotion within you and that maybe
it reminds you of some memory that your
mom or dad said to you or in that moment
you make it mean
something so there's some emotion that
gets elicited
and then the main problem is that
emotion
creates an amygdala hijack essentially
you're unaware
of the action that you then take and
that's really
sort of the problem with the argument
hangover is because you
do more damage and you extend the
argument hangover
because you're unconscious of the then
triggered behavior
that you take automatically don't have
to even think about it
i had donald robertson who's a cbt
trained stoic philosopher so this guy's
got the new age and the old age
all combined together and he was talking
about how much our judgment is impaired
when we're angry
and he said that anger is one of the
worst
uh impacts that we can have on our
judgment and i'm going to guess that one
of the most common
emotions that people find when they get
emotionally triggered is anger
oh it's intoxicating it releases
chemicals in your body and you're not
really
thinking straight however people can
train themselves
to interrupt it so it is possible to not
do the damage that's normally caused
by the triggered behaviors and it takes
practice just like everything that you
teach
you can't just learn something in a book
and then be like oh i tried it one day
and it didn't work
right it's practice months and years and
to your point right like if a couple
really is aligned
and they even think they're perfect for
each other and they both do
self-development
we work with a lot of couples who've
done years of self-development and
they're like
my partner still triggers me so are they
not the right person then
no that's means it's pointing to
something within you
to look at and go at where is this in
the past and
and that's really where i mean we just
really have transformed
as powerful in any relationship then we
were talking earlier about you either
approach it as a boxing match or or
being a football team right approaching
a game or a match so in those moments
if someone your friend a family member
comes to you and
and they're triggered rather than
getting so defensive
and trying to to stop their pattern or
behavior don't speak to me that way
if you could just pause and say hey you
know it seems seems like you're
triggered
that's how you start to make that shift
from a boxing match to being
on the same team you know in a match
together is
hey seems like you're triggered is that
right what emotion is there for you so
you've already stopped the pattern for
them
and now you're helping them be
introspective of what is the emotion
ideally if you can get to what the event
was and then not just apologize
i'm so sorry i did that to make you feel
that way
the self-realization then says what
meaning did
i give to that event that caused that
within me
not trying to get your partner to now
stop doing all of the triggering events
so that you don't get triggered
have you seen chris fosse's work have
you read much of that stuff
yeah amazing so
yeah he's amazing he came on the show a
couple of months ago
and obviously he's got that um it seems
like there's something on your mind
it seems like there's something on your
mind it feels like there's something
that you need to talk about
like that and you don't realize until
you speak to someone like him who's
obviously an absolute elite
of communication you don't realize just
how disarming
that sentence is it's amazing
it seems like there's something on your
mind and you just realize like it's not
judgmental
it's not even what's wrong like what's
wrong
has everyone's had that asked by a
partner and there's
there is a fair bit of baggage that kind
of comes along with that like
it seems like there's something on your
mind and you just go like
uh and you just seem to open up it's
such a softening sentence
it really is it's powerful that you
bring that up too because one thing we
talk about in our book
and you talk about archetypes where we
have four communication personality
types
of you and your partner which then leads
to ten different
dynamics but often an assertive partner
would be with a more reserve partner so
maybe one that's not
speaking up as much and so this
conversation can be well that's great
but my partner doesn't share
so to your point chris voss has a
technique called
mirroring and so for the reserve
partners if you mirror
and then for those of you that haven't
read the book if you just repeat the
last
one to three words that your partner
says
then for instance maybe they come to you
and say i can't believe you did that
did that and you raise the inflection of
your voice
that person is going to basically
automatically take it deeper
so it's a powerful place though for
those that are assertive and reserved to
use this mirroring to help your partner
go a little bit deeper with it
well and to that point because and i
love that chris voss like we have so
much aligned with him
is communication because i'm sure so
many people
in relationships identify communication
is the biggest
challenge i mean we've done over 44
couples workshops
and the number one reason couples attend
is communication communication
but here's what's interesting and i'm
sure you might run into this or already
have
in your dating experiences even if you
meet someone who's doing
self-development and they're like yeah
i'm really working on my communication
they get frustrated like i don't think
you're that's really working on your
communication like the way you're doing
it
is not right and so then they can kind
of judge the way they're communicating
so we say communication is not one size
fits all
and that's why we created the four
communication personality types
because different approaches are needed
for different types
different tempos different uh how much
time each person needs to process
so i'd say for those of you who are
similar to you who are wanting to
attract
that great partner is to realize that
they still might be working on being a
great communicator
it might not just look exactly like you
what are the different types and how
should people utilize them
yeah so there are it's in a four
quadrants basically like a normal two by
two grid right and you fall into one of
the four
so there's assertive inflexible
assertive
flexible reserved inflexible and
reserved flexible
so assertiveness to reserve some people
go oh i'm assertive because i talk a lot
that's not true assertiveness in the
sense that we mean assertiveness is
the openness and willingness to share
your thoughts
needs emotions proactively
so not in a reactive manner once you're
already upset
it's asserting yourself ahead of time
before it's even become a challenge
more reserved people it doesn't mean
that they never will open up
it's more so that they usually take more
time to process their thoughts and
emotions
they need to be asked in a different way
they need it to
even not be just sitting kind of with
all the attention on them
so that's the assertive to reserve scale
and then flexibility to inflexibility
measures
how open and willing you are to adjust
your perspective
your behaviors within the relationship
based on what's needed in that moment
like different seasons different seasons
of a relationship
kind of in a way call for different
perspectives and behaviors
and so that's flexibility to
inflexibility and
what does that mean for people how
should they utilize those with regards
to their communication
well let's do our example of our two
types well so jocelyn
jocelyn is and when we talk about like
assertive inflexible
you could probably fall into a different
type in a work setting or with family
and friends
and even different aspects of your
romantic relationship so we have people
look at
when you are triggered when you have
emotion come up what do you sort of
default to
so jocelyn's really is assertive
inflexible where mine is
reserved inflexible to where if jocelyn
immediately shares something that and i
get defensive
i'm going to more so shut down
i'm going to pretty much like stop
talking if we're driving in the car i
might look out the window
and though i felt like that was better
than
reacting back raising my voice saying
whatever came to my mind i initially
thought that was better but
here comes to find out jocelyn feels
pushed away she feels isolated
and it it disconnects us it separates us
so what i learned for me being a reserve
type
is i don't have to become assertive but
i want to
at least engage into the conversation by
saying something to jocelyn like hey
jocelyn i'm realizing i'm i'm triggered
and i'd like a few minutes to process my
emotions
you know can we come back to this in
five minutes so i'm not feeling
pressured by jocelyn to stay in the
conversation say what i'm feeling
talk before i'm ready but i need to
start to share
where i'm at so that we can stay engaged
into a conversation and come back to it
at a time that's going to be more suited
for a reserve
and then on the assertive partner one of
the mistakes i used to make
being with a reserve partner was if i
want to talk about it i'ma bring it up
right now
and that would blindside him and because
he needs more time
to process his thoughts and emotions he
would shut down which would then
frustrate me so then i'd over compensate
even more
and it would then become this power
struggle and turn into a disagreement
so now what i do this is just one of the
the ways it's
impactful is i give him a heads up if
there's something we're going to talk
about that's actually important
i mean and i know it seems like it's so
simple but it makes all the difference
if we're going to talk about having kids
instead of me blindsiding him
on a hike hey i'd like to talk about
starting a family and i know you like to
think about things ahead of time
would you feel up for discussing it on
our hike this weekend
anything it could be finances it could
be your intimacy even if i want to talk
about our relationship i don't say hey
we need to talk
right now about something that happened
i give him a heads up about it and
hasn't made a difference totally yeah i
don't i don't feel
blindsided when i feel blindsided what
else is there for me to do except be
defensive so we're already again in the
boxing match rather than
being on the same team which type do you
think you fall into the assertive and
flexible
assertive flexible reserved and flexible
or reserved flexible
i'd say probably assertive inflexible
um okay although if any of my exes are
watching
then just comment below and let me know
that'll be interesting um
they're not gonna be watching uh one of
the things i've been interested in
is how much
individuals should share
in the context of couple dialogue so i
understand
that becoming emotionally triggered with
things and opening up about the way that
you feel
and also warning someone that
something's going to come up and all the
rest of it
there has to be a glass ceiling on how
much you can break the fourth wall
around the inner workings of your own
mind
and speaking from personal experience
when
i feel like i have nothing left to find
out about the person that there's
nothing new and nothing spontaneous
occurring
and also the fact that a lot of what
goes on within our heads we may say
here's a thing that i'm feeling but 10
minutes later or 15 minutes later be
like
yeah actually that just dissipated i
probably shouldn't have brought that up
is the how can people know when they're
over sharing essentially you know they
might think right relationship skills
brilliant justin and aaron have said
i'm going to develop my relationship
skills how do they not overshare
so what i'm hearing in that is in a way
like do i need to share
every thought and emotion that i have
it's an interesting question what we
would really do
because we have practices where even
though we are so open in our
communication
every single morning we have time just
with ourselves so we meditate
we journal after this is after exercise
and
we process a lot of what's there now do
we
share every single thought no i don't
think so i think
if it's actually important to have a
series of questions that you may have
seen
that have you kind of clarify is this
something actually important to me
versus is this a blip
you know we would call it is it just a
blip moment so there's some great
questions to kind of be able to reflect
so if it isn't a blip
meaning it really isn't that significant
it was just a momentary thing
and it's actually important we will
share it but we definitely
reflect before we share a lot with each
other like we
really have worked to not just
reactively bring something up in the
heat of a moment
what would you say well i think so far
in this conversation talking about
emotional triggers
it can seem like we're talking about
things from the past you know
healing and evolving from there but now
we're missing
basically the point of being a
relationship is to create
to imagine the future that isn't yet
that we are stepping into and creating
by being in a relationship
so i think to your point do i need to
share every emotion and feeling
at some point you've really cleared up
the past so now you're free
to create anything you want you know the
nature of consciousness the nature of
being alive it's infinite so
when we talk about a space of infinite
possibilities
you get excitement you can be have high
anticipation
we want to travel what kind of
experiences do we want to have do we
want to be influential do we want to
start a business start a family you know
now you're into the imagination
of the whole purpose of why you're
together
and you know looking at consciousness
our
outer world is actually a reflection of
our inner world
of what we are imagining what we are
already feeling
as already being done that's a really
powerful exciting conversation to be
imagining with your partner
which once you clear up the past that's
where we want people to live all the
time
absolutely i mean very much our thoughts
shape the world around us we don't exist
in the world we exist in the mental
model
that our brain has constructed of the
world and
the more baggage and extra bits that you
don't need the more drag is on that
mental model the more cognitive biases
you have the less rationality the less
balance all that sort of stuff
um so i mean that that sounds like a
wonderful situation to be in but
i imagine that you both need to work
through an awful lot before you get
there and inevitably that's going to
involve going through conflict so how
can you turn that conflict into a good
thing
i love that because we didn't come to
each other as you heard like all shiny
ready-made i
i transformed everything right and maybe
you will show up for a partner that way
but i
would bet you that there would be new
things that come up for you
i'm perfect don't worry about that i
know you've already
worked through it all so conflict
yes we see that as something that really
is showing something
inside of us and we also so we have this
whole
five-hour process to truly reconcile
after
a conflict because just saying i'm sorry
is not enough
it doesn't truly repair things
afterwards and one of the five r's that
i think is important to your question
is the fifth r which is to reconcile the
conflict
as an opportunity together so we
actually just had a session with a
couple right before this
and there was something that came up
between them the last couple of weeks
and how she remembered it
was that was a bummer that was
frustrating it got us
off course slowed our momentum we were
doing so well before
and there was a lot of discouraged
feeling in that
and so we said okay let's change the way
you remember it
let's reconcile the situation as an
opportunity
and i'm telling you it's it's totally
different
after our disagreements we always go
great what did we learn about ourselves
as individuals
what did we learn about our relationship
and what our relationship needs because
you may or may not have heard this
before but we see our relationship as a
separate entity
from who we are so after that conflict
what did we now learn our relationship
needs and then also how are we better
how are we stronger
and when we change the way we remember
it
we actually saw the possibility that was
available
conflicts aren't a problem they really
create a whole new possibility
that's interesting and also ties in with
a lot of
what i believe around the way that we
act as humans
like the fact is that nothing is really
good or bad it's all just a learning
experience
and if you lean into the discomfort as a
feature of life not a book
you are going to encounter things that
are going to go wrong you're going to
encounter catastrophe both chosen and
unchosen both
by your uh doings and by other people's
doings
um and the only way that you really can
go through that is to think okay what
did i learn
from that and it's one of the beauties
of trying to cultivate curiosity
that if you're if you're interested in
what's coming next you're very rarely
scared about what's going to happen
you're just constantly thinking oh how
interesting isn't this like even
the level of equanimity that i think we
all should aspire to get toward
is that when you sense an emotion you
don't attach yourself to the emotion but
you question
wow how interesting that i'm feeling
this why isn't that cool
that isn't the the sensation of
nervousness i've got this
sensation in my stomach and i can feel
myself getting hot up towards my cheeks
and
you know all of the different things
that you feel um but it takes an awful
lot of work to get there as you say
um i also think as well the
reconciliation thing ties in with the
peak end rule
are you familiar with this from
psychology so ben hardy who's a mutual a
mutual friend of ours
um he he talks about this so the pecan
effect is a daniel kahneman study
and what they realized was that the two
biggest retainers in terms of memory
from any event
are the most emotionally intense and the
end so
they put people through endoscopies
which are quite uncomfortable where you
get a camera inside of you
and they were able to give people a
little roller where they could rate out
of 10 how much pain they were in
and then they asked them to
retrospectively
look at how much pain they had been in
after the event
so during the event they're moving this
camera around and basically the more
movement equates to more
discomfort so they have um two things
two controls that they can work out
fairly easily like look this is movement
which should equal pain
in one of them the pain went to a higher
peak
but lasted for longer and then dipped
down at the end
and in the other one it was fairly flat
and peaked
and then tailed off and sort of finished
as soon as it was done
what they found was that in the version
the iteration of the study
where people had had their procedure
elongated
but the elongation was a much lower
level
they retrospectively uh classified it as
being lower pain
even though they've been under a higher
peak and a longer amount of time
and he one of the weird things that they
talk about from this is that if you have
a child who's going in
for an operation one of the most
compassionate things that you can do
especially something like the dentist
that's going to be perhaps uncomfortable
one of the most compassionate things
that you can do is to
try and extend the procedure out so that
the
end of the peak end rule has this
low discomfort because that sort of
thing is what can impact
children growing up into adulthood being
having a fear of the dentist for the
rest of their lives
and when you think about okay
retrospectively i'm going to look back
on this argument
what is the last thing that i'm going to
remember from this argument
is it doors slamming in me walking out
going out the house that perhaps might
even be the peak as well
um or is it going to be us going look
this is something that we need to work
together on that's hug that's blah blah
blah
candles and a bath and whatever it might
be and it might
i love that and that was such a great
depiction of that principle
and correlating it to arguments and what
i'll say for some people because i don't
want people to think oh wow
it's going to take us a while to get to
the point where we're reconciling this
within the conflict itself
sometimes it's a separate moment like
sometimes there might be especially
for the peak maybe you both get
triggered and you're saying and doing
things that aren't constructive so
you're like okay let's
call a timeout then you take a break
and what we'd say is don't let the break
be too too long though
sometimes people will let it be days
before they've really come back together
and they're kind of giving each other
the one-word answers and they're just
getting by
and so the reconciliation might be an
hour later
like there's nothing wrong with
sometimes people go
no let's solve this right now we're not
stopping this conversation until this is
complete and that might push someone
especially a reserved partner
they need to scale back and go on their
own they silently process
assertive people can usually talk it out
and
process through their thoughts by being
heard but a reserve partner
mostly needs a moment to reflect and
what am i feeling and so that can push a
partner if you're trying to be like no
we need to solve it right now
but to your point yes and it just might
be a conversation like an hour later
well remember as well just how much our
judgment is skewed by being angry
like even just allowing yourself to dial
down from the peak of that anger
would probably be a pretty good idea so
what about let's talk about before
comfort obviously
the best thing to do presumably would be
to not have arguments
or to try and limit the conflicts that
we do have
but if it's going to happen what can we
do before we have a conflict
well yeah yeah you know to that point
it's not necessarily the conflict right
it's again in how we see it we would say
the goal would be to shorten the
argument hangover
and keep it from escalating to the
levels of either doing
more damage or just pitting you against
each other
so just again going to the sports
analogy it's like well
maybe we'll be better if we have less
conflicts meaning we have less tough
matches but that's just not the case the
the tougher matches you have with an
opponent the better that you get
so i wouldn't necessarily say it's about
reducing the conflict as much as
those things that i had just mentioned
and ways you can do that
it's so simple but just having
agreements so we'll link back to the
emotional triggers
again with any relationship it could be
a son or daughter it could be a friend
another family member family member
co-worker and then spouse
if there's something you notice in that
relationship you often get triggered by
what you want to do is come to them and
say hey you know what i realized
i often get triggered by you saying
x now i know i'm giving that meaning but
it would really help me if we could
create an agreement that you wouldn't
bring that up
when when we have an argument and then
just pick like four of these
because i think four is reasonable it's
not too many to remember
and then when that argument happens
you can remind each other of the
agreements that you had
this will keep it from escalating doing
more damage or pitting you against each
other which would ultimately
lengthen that argument hangover and it
will make it easier for you to
reconcile the conflict into the
opportunity for
strength for understanding you know
going back to
chris voss and empathy it's all a game
of empathy and the more we can
understand one another
just the better connections we have with
life
what are some of the examples of things
that people might say they don't want to
be
brought up well so the agreements can
really be
you know based on what your triggered
behaviors are so i had a tendency of
yelling
and wanting to bring up the past a lot
oh this is exactly like this and
i need he i need to connect all the dots
so we have an agreement of no raising
our
voice so actually the moment that we
start to raise our voice we remind each
other hey that's not constructive here
and then also no bringing up the past is
one
we also cannot do any name calling and
also
yeah so for the reserve
the reserved i noticed that
to really benefit both of us i'm going
to agree not
to shut down and like say
nothing you know remove my attention or
energy from that conversation
leaving the room and in with that would
be also like turning my back
and just leaving more more obvious one
but for me it's really
speaking up and just saying either i'm
triggered or i'm
feeling something and making some sort
of request so simply put the agreement
for me as
not to shut down what about arguments
we're in the argument how can we have
better arguments yeah so now you're
already you're in the during
which you again you're human being so no
matter how much conscious work you do
your partner might trigger you so what i
would do
besides what we talked about with the
agreements if you're already in that
disagreement
is to learn how to be a better listener
and
what unfortunately people do is when
their partner is triggered they're
really just listening to the superficial
answers that their partner is giving the
literal words and you may have seen in
our book we have three columns
what it looks like to not be listening
at all what it is to just hear
and then what is truly listening so
not hearing at all would be that he
shares an emotion
so we're in an argument and he says make
up a statement here
i can't believe you just said that well
i didn't just say that you're totally
mis
understanding that's even an agreement i
can't believe you just broke that
agreement i wasn't
listening i basically wasn't listening
at all right i dismissed so
not listening at all as being dismissive
invalidating that's not correct
you're just pretty much listening to
that voice in your head of what you
agree with what you don't agree with
what you can justify
evidence that you have so then if i were
to take that same statement that he said
and
actually or only here i'd be like
no that's but that's not what i said so
i didn't react as much but i'm like
saying no that's not true so i only
listen to the words
if i was truly listening i could say
back oh did something i say hurt you
so listening is about how can i
empathize
i'm not just listening to the literal
words my partner is saying
i'm listening for the emotion they're
trying to communicate because our
partner will often say things
that seem like they're just logical but
there's some emotion that's trying to be
communicated right underneath it
but we aren't trained to be good
listeners we're really only trained to
be hearers
and this is what really i think i worked
on a lot was realizing that listening is
not a passive activity
you're not just automatically listening
to your partner
even in times of conflict you likely are
hearing things but it's going through
your filter
and it's going through the do i agree do
i disagree do i need to defend myself
that whole filter truly listening
takes so much attention so much
like awareness and presence and most
people
don't even practice that like how can i
listen so
purposefully right now that i'm actually
hearing the emotion that's being called
even further that you empathy or like
chris voss would say empathy is
feeling well technically sympathy is
feeling
with them empathy is actually feeling
in them which whole of the conversation
but you're actually
feeling what they're feeling saying wow
it really sounds like
you're upset sounds like you're really
angry you know tell me more about that
it's really kind of like getting to the
black swan
as chris would say
[Music]
what about people who are passive
aggressive this is
me speaking from personal experience um
not as the passive-aggressive one at
least i don't think i am but
that triggers in me passive
aggressiveness
triggers in me something from the
seventh circle of dante's hell
uh and also seems to be a little bit of
a
a catch-all for stopping productive
conversation
because it's it's both dismissive but
aggressive
it's not engaging but it's also kind of
leaving
it's like curling a turd out in the
middle of the room and then leaving it
there and being like
this is just what i'm gonna leave you
with have you got any strategies for how
people can deal with a
passive aggressive partner well one
quick thing before you go
it's just great to identify that's most
likely from a reserve type of partner
so just even categorizing yourself into
the archetype reserves
probably inflexibles those that have not
been sharing you've got something built
up
it's wanting to get expressed but
because you're more reserved it's going
to be like
i'm just going to leave it on the floor
and then you deal with that so of course
there's
the partner that is passive aggressive
and them
in a calm state bringing it up to them
and being like hey
i noticed there's this pattern that
happens is that something you're
open to looking at right so that person
would ideally be open to looking at
where that being passive aggressive
comes from
then there's to what you said if you're
the one that's with the passive
aggressive partner
then what you could say is hey it sounds
like there's actually something else you
want to communicate
and you didn't say what you really would
like to share i'd love to know that
so we can especially if our partner is
trying to change a pattern
and that's the big thing i get messages
all the time from people like my
partner's really trying to change the
pattern how can i continue to be patient
how can i continue but and that's what
it takes right
if they're actively working on changing
the pattern we want to hold space for
them
we want to have the patience for them so
it's like hey that pattern thing
you know is coming up again but i do
want to know what you truly mean
so please share with me and hopefully
that
change in reaction will kind of snap
them into like whoa
i wasn't even aware i did that because
it's so unconscious it's a protection
mechanism
maybe they grew up in a household where
it wasn't safe for them to share their
emotions
maybe that's all they saw their mom or
dad do
and so i'm sure they're not sitting
there going i want to be passive
aggressive right now
right that's not really a conscious
choice a lot of times
so you want to even share to them in a
loving way that you observed it
and then if you change your reaction to
them it can change the whole pattern
between the two of you
i imagine the it seems like from chris
would be another
great way to try and elicit a response
yeah yeah it seems like there's
something else that you'd like to say
right now
i'd love to know what that is that's the
master key that's the that's the cheat
code for people who are passive
aggressive for anyone that's listening
what about afterwards
how how can we how can we make that
after an argument the hangover period
actually be reduced once it's
uh happened yeah so in the post-conflict
stage we do have the five
r's which would take more time to go
through all five of them and i did tell
you the reconcile one
i would say because it's really the
first two steps are on your own so that
you can reflect and really see
where you played a part in it but to
your question i think the one i want to
focus on is actually the third r
which is to reconnect and this is this
is what's
um no the third one the fourth
okay fourth one argument
over our own book so oh no you're right
oh oh yeah we've just seen it we've just
seen it play out in front of us here
i was actually gonna let it go though
did you notice where i didn't fight
for it i just was like it's not that
important
but it's okay i know he's wrong anyway
so i didn't have my ego didn't flare up
there's no need for me to hold this i
know i'm right yeah
the ego was tame just now so
the third arc being reconnect what's
challenging about this one is that
especially
if there was more damage done during the
disagreement
our ego does want to stay distant it
wants to protect itself and you need to
come to me
and it will it will tolerate distance
physical
and emotional for days i mean we've
talked to couples that are married with
kids and they're tolerating weeks of
distance
they're letting that simmer in their
house and so the third r being reconnect
is to
reconnect faster don't let it drag on
and you might not be full-blown ready to
be intimate physically and sexually
but tell them you know a pat on the back
hey
i do want to reconnect i care about you
i love you
we're gonna resolve this i'm still
reflecting and i maybe still need some
more time but i'm
letting him know i'm still on the team
and i'm making the physical touch which
reminds him that i love him
and so that reconnect stage is
challenging but so
important
[Music]
i was thinking about how challenging
that may be for people with regards to
getting over their own ego i don't want
to be the first one to make the move
should it be a should it be a case of
you being cognizant when the other
partner does that should it be a tit for
tat like he did it last time it's my
turn now
i know that comes up you know and that
was actually what
gets you into the conversation is to
share where you saw responsibility
and i again to your point often
at least i can speak for men it's like
hey
i can really be past this all you have
to do is admit
where you were at ball and i'm ready to
move past this right
but to really have strong relationships
and to
really resolve conflicts emotionally
just step up to be the leader don't look
at if you had responsibility
just look for where you can take
responsibility
that person was obviously in a
conversation with you so there is
something some reaction some tone
or something you forgot to do that kept
this conflict
going longer or escalated the way that
it did
and then so going to your point you know
with with ben hardy
there is that sort of reciprocity
right there's also mirror neurons so
either either one of those ones that you
want to use when you come to your
partner and you lead first by saying
here's where i see i'm taking
responsibility
often the other partner is going to say
you know what
where i see responsibility for myself is
this so
if you can just try going first i think
you will often
see that the other partner will meet you
there too it seems to me
like so many of the challenges that
relationships come up against are these
self-fulfilling spirals of
resentment and passive aggressiveness
and argument and clanging and
unresolved problems and more tension and
more tension and more and more and more
and more more and it just winds up
as opposed to the other side of this
which is when you can start to break
that cycle
so i'm going to guess that one of the
keys is to try and set the tone
early in a relationship as well as you
can obviously
you can't go back and restart the
relationship so you need to
start from where you are but upon
beginning a relationship
trying to make this the modus operandi
for how people go about things i'm going
to guess is a good way also i have a
buddy savann matosian do you know who
that is
i don't know that name so he is the
ex-head of crossfit media
but he's made a name for himself
raising his three kids so him and his
wife have
a boy who's six and two twin boys who
are three
and he has a very progressive way that
he brings them up there
remembering the names of capital cities
whilst balancing on a balancing board
his kids just done 140 days of
skateboarding in a row he's a gray belt
in brazilian jiu jitsu and
all of these sorts of things um and one
of the tools that he has
with his partner is when whenever they
argue they
always make up in front of the kids even
if they didn't argue in front of the
kids
that we say the same thing i think
that's a really cool heuristic
someone without kids but it just seems
like a really good way to
show your children look like this is how
things
happen because as a kid your emotional
intelligence isn't sufficiently
developed to understand that
i might have overheard mum and dad
having an argument earlier on
but i never actually knew if they made
up they might have made up in the car on
the way to work or over a text message
or on a phone call or when i went to bed
and you're just left thinking well maybe
i'm going to be that's it like off to
the orphanage i go
yeah yes totally you want to let them
see
you repair it parting thoughts then any
things that you think that we haven't
covered so far
any tips that people should take away
that they can enact this straight away
i think just really focus on the way to
improve the relationship is by learning
relationship skills and there's nothing
wrong with you with your partner your
with your relationship like if you
genuinely feel in alignment between the
two of you
then focus on learning those skills and
of course we'd love to be a part of that
whether
you read our book or just follow us on
social media we want to support you in
gaining those relationship skills
why should people go to check out your
stuff well since we're in book promotion
mode for the argument hangover as we've
referenced
uh we have several 200 worth of
pre-order bonuses that are definitely
worth grabbing a copy even before it
hits shelves
and that's at the argumenthangover.com
and then we're on social media
we're meet underscore the freemans and
we're super engaged on there
yeah those are the two then that of
course instagram just links you to
everything else that we have
perfect guys thank you very much for
today hopefully we'll have saved some
relationships or at least reduce the
volume of some arguments you've asked
some great questions thank you so much
for today
thank you chris my pleasure
[Music]
you